[music playing]
NARRATOR: Across the
globe, over 1.5 billion
people believe in
reincarnation, including
nearly all Eastern philosophies
as well as the Kabbalistic sect
of Judaism.
Tibetans, we believe rebirth.
In the Kabbalistic
tradition of Judaism,
reincarnation is considered
a fundamental belief.
And unlike other religions,
which believe you have only one
lifetime in which
to get it right,
in the Kabbalistic
tradition, it is
believed that souls are
given multiple chances
to get it right.
So souls are believed to
reincarnate time after time.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The idea of the
preexistence of the soul
was once a significant doctrine
of the Christian canon,
before it had been
excised from the teachings
by Roman Emperor Justinian
the Great in 553 AD.
The early Christian
belief in reincarnation
was eventually
declared a heresy.
Instead of recycling to
earth over and over again,
you now only have one
destination after this life.
That destination is either
Heaven or it's Hell,
depending on how
you behaved in life.
It was used as a
control mechanism.
JONATHAN YOUNG:
In ancient Greece,
Socrates, Pythagoras,
and Plato all
commented on the possibility
of reincarnation.
In the dialogues, Plato says,
"I am confident that there truly
is such a thing as living
again, and that the living
spring from the dead."
So here's a strong
sense of reincarnation.
CAROLINE CORY: There are
many beliefs around the world
that reincarnation exists.
Some people believe that
certain types of souls
are able to come back--
not just in one body, but
in several bodies at once--
to perform specific tasks.
And that's one of
the reasons why there
are so many more
people on the earth
today than there used to be.
And, also, it is
possible for you
to reincarnate
from other planets.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS:
Oftentimes, when reincarnation
is discussed, we only
talk about it that people
are reincarnated here on Earth.
And I personally always thought
that that was a limiting idea
of reincarnation.
I think even
extraterrestrial organisms--
biological ones--
would be reincarnated
throughout the universe.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: If souls
are indeed recycling
through various bodies--
as so many cultures both ancient
and modern have proposed--
is this simply the natural
continuation of life,
or might this
process be directed
toward some greater end?
One that reaches
far beyond Earth.
Perhaps further clues can be
found by examining the stories
of those who claim to
have been reincarnated
with a specific
purpose for humanity.
[explosion]